hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to monstrum now
we've got a plan of attack and we're not
gonna flail around and die to horrible
monstrosities from half the world away
this time anyway and i know you guys
love it when i die and fail horribly or
maybe i'm just fooling myself into
believing that
but this time i have a plan and i'm not
gonna stop until i actually get to the
end of this game
which is hopefully gonna be soon but
it's gonna take a lot of steps to get
from that point to this point so there's
gonna be a lot of cutting in between
i know what i need to do i know what i
need to avoid or i think i do anyway so
long as it's not the black oozy creature
that i really don't like and it's big
red guy
i think i'm gonna be okay but if it is
black oozy creature that creates sticky
traps that i slip and fall and smash my
face into
hey i'm gonna have a bad time all right
okay okay so i need duct tape a pump
and then i need to find i already have
i have a fuse and i have a plan
they think they can get me huh they too
sassy
they're too sassy i'm too sassy either
way there's far
too much sass going on are you going to
be good to me
are you going to give me the things that
i need i think i'm in luck guys
i think i'm in luck cause i see on the
other side of this door a spool of chain
which is the other ingredient that i
almost forgot about and hopefully no
one's gonna find out that i'm here
so all i need now is a duct tape and a
pump so if i can find that pump i'm
going to be glad
i'm gonna go ahead and go up because if
i can go up
now then i can drop off the chain and
see if there's actually some things i
need
on the way up as opposed to having to go
back down
into the basement which i would prefer
not to considering there's monsters and
death there
and stupid steam that's gonna stop me
from proceeding
oh it's dark i see the vents there does
that mean mr
mr grabby hands is gonna be
okay hey oh god the camera is more scary
than the monsters
actually that's a total lie the monsters
are terrifying
i got duct tape and now i just need a
pump
oh if i can get that pianist pump i'll
be so happy
what's this what's that neck timer i
don't need that oh i don't need that
that's a soundy noise
okay what this this doesn't do jack
doodly
it's so quiet i got a lot of the
supplies that i need and i haven't even
heard big red or
slimy slew i think it's slimy slew who's
coming out this time
because this is obviously not going to
be a good thing
oh yeah it's quiet
i just need to get the chain on here is
that actually a thing
i'm just worried he's gonna come
crawling out of the shadows i'm not
gonna be able to see him
okay so i got that now i just need to
fix all the
holes in it and then i need to pump it
up lower it
and not jump off the boat like a [ __ ]
because why would any sane person
actually do that so now i just go all
the way down
into the basement because i i think the
pump
is probably only available in like the
shipping container area
oh that was steam god damn it uh panic
over nothing
oh god damn it
what the frick frack what the [ __ ]
[ __ ]
jesus oh god don't kill me see not now
i've been so fortunate
except for this time jesus hell
oh god oh god oh god open open open
i got no time i don't know where i'm
going oh god if this leaks to a dead end
i'm so bound
let's close it oh jeez
steve don't kill me steam no kelly see
no countless you don't kill me
[ __ ]
oh god oh that's not good this is a dead
end
okay so i just happened to run into the
unfortunate situation
of him popping up immediately in front
of me
i think he's triggered by sound i don't
much care for it
what is that yeah that doesn't look good
it looks like egg sacs sacks of eggs
who put all this poop in my pants
okay so that's my light i've been here
before
but i didn't drop down here oh this was
a bad place to drop
there's a thing uh that's not the thing
i need though but i'm i'm getting to the
things actually
so i just need to find more things so if
a god damn it
uh oh i'm hyper ventilating
this is a stressful scenario
what the [ __ ]
what the baloney are you kidding me i
didn't why
where was he
i didn't even get a warning i didn't
even get a goddamn
warning what a son of a [ __ ]
oh i'm not lucky enough to get exactly
what i need right here
i got a flare is that a flare again
why do i need a flare gun can i shoot it
in one of their faces you better back
off big red
i'm a security guard with a flare gun
i'm on the edge
i'm uncontrollable no one can satiate my
bloodlust
with my flare gun you think you got a
big red face now
this way i taste the heaty justice of my
flare gun
anybody anybody want to taste the fiery
justice of my flare gun
sorry i apologize for my spit last time
i get almost exactly what i need this
time i get almost nothing to what i
need great
ah flare gun oh that did nothing hold
that what about this
i got up
this is not going well for me it was
gonna be so good
i how did i die to the shadow creature
ah i had it perfectly i just needed the
penis
pump i mean life raft pump
i'm a security guard at night
gonna check all the rooms making music
with my flashlight
that's a little cup breakable and stuff
gonna make noise when i need it
oh crap oh hi um how about you come this
way i got a looping circle to go through
yeah that's right yeah you do that thing
yeah
it's a weird yeah yeah go this way yeah
come through here
great idea you better god yeah you
better have gone through there you son
of a [ __ ]
there it is the jumpy pump i found the
yumpy pump everybody
okay so the yumpy pump is good because
that seems to be the hardest thing to
actually find around here
so now that i got the yumpy pump i'm
gonna be able to do what i need to do
let's hope that these shipping
containers are fortunate and have lots
of goodie goods well if i could find a
goddamn entrance that'd be sure helpful
yeah yeah yeah well there's more goopy
goose
i don't want to touch those that's not a
spool of chain
that's not a spool of chain at all i
need a spoola chain
ah that's not what i need either god
damn it come on give me something i need
i don't want to cure any of the other
things i just want to fix my life
rafting girl
ah what the [ __ ] jesus christ holy crap
yeah balderoni
these don't help me either i
am running away oh anything in here
anything in here anything in here
anything here nothing nothing nothing a
whole lot of nothing
god damn why it's gotta be something
oh this was a stupid idea at least i got
the duct tape
on the run with duct tape
crap oh crap hide hide hide hide hide
oh i'm gonna wait here a little
bit just to make sure the ghost is clear
does my chain hang low does it wobble to
and fro is it right in the kitchen or is
it anywhere i don't know i haven't seen
it but i really wish it was here oh my
god i want to change so bad
unless this just leads back to the same
place then that don't matter
what that's a bad thing what the hell
how the hell did that happen
where did it come from where'd it go
where did it come from cow nigel give me
the [ __ ] up there
i don't know if this was a good idea
okay
oh [ __ ] but jesus where is he
what the [ __ ] oh where is he i can't see
him oh [ __ ]
where is he there's only one way up here
there's only one staircase
uh i'm trying to look i'm trying to look
i'm trying to look oh i see him okay
he's coming
okay run run run run run now is the time
to run close this door and then be on my
way
ah yeah [ __ ] oh god that almost got
me oh piss oh piss i'm not going the
right way
god i meant to be around that area damn
it damn it damn it damn it all the hell
not what i wanted not what i wanted not
what i wanted it's weird i've been
through this place so many times now i'm
actually kind of remembering
where i'm going and where i am my
orientation is actually getting a lot
better than it was
um because yeah i'm on decks three which
means that i've explored pretty much
every nook and cranny that was on this
level i don't think the chain is here i
think the chain is actually
on the end i'm on the south end of the
ship right now and i think that i have
to go to the other side if i'm going to
be able to do anything
there you are jesus oh my god
i found you finally holy
hell if anything gets in the way of me
and that goddamn raft it's going to get
murdered like literally i am so
done with this baloney
baloney baloney
blooney baloony you guys do not know how
long i have been wandering
and wandering and wandering and
wandering and wandering and wandering
wandering and wandering one i think i've
been wandering so long that the monster
just kind of gave up and went to sleep
it was so tired of waiting for me to
actually do
something no monster sneak up behind me
and kill me not that so far yet davis
damn it that stack
well put it on the thing well this was
easy before
oh that's not what i wanted to do put on
the thing
what am i doing what the what am i doing
what how does this not line up anymore
th
this this is not how this went before i
are you serious now you screwing with me
you can't be serious
you you you can't this doesn't
settle the line up anymore [ __ ] god damn
it what the [ __ ]
jesus you're not going to kill me now
jesus christmas well that's not what i
wanted to do hey
it's not where i wanted to go at all
chimney christmas you got to be joking
with me
god what the [ __ ] what are you doing
just camping up here
oh god damn it did i just really just uh
no stop it
where is it oh
no no
where was it you gotta be kidding me
an hour and 12 minutes i've been trying
that [ __ ]
and it wouldn't line up what the baloney
where was he
oh my god you gotta be kidding me i'm
not done with this you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you piece of [ __ ] you
goddamn
bastard you ugly [ __ ] alien
piece of [ __ ]
vampire blood sucking loser of a monster
for the past 20 minutes the frame rate
has dropped to like 15
frames per second and i don't know why
probably because i've been playing the
game so long and it's got like a memory
log
back up but man it's been nauseating i'm
i'm literally thinking i'm about to
vomit and i've been
[ __ ] everywhere i have been
[ __ ] everywhere trying to look for
what it wants me to find but god damn it
i've been playing this game for now an
hour and 45 minutes just
looping through over and over and this
[ __ ] will not end the only thing
that's keeping me going is the mantra
that
i will not let this become another
vanish
i won't [ __ ] that this is
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm so angry
i'm so nauseous i can't
i just don't want to play anymore but
i'm not gonna let it beat me
because [ __ ] that that's the only thing
i got left
oh [ __ ] god damn it jesus
i was one step away from getting the
[ __ ]
oh god from getting the sub done
oh my god i can't i had to go out and
take a breather and then restart the
game because it was some problem that
was causing the frames to drop
so hopefully now that the frames are
better i'll be less nauseous while
playing this
and then i'll be able to go oh man
oh man this is probably the most
grueling playthrough i've ever done just
because i am still
sick and i'm trying to beat this i was
so eager i was so close
twice in a row god damn oh man
oh man getting [ __ ] over is just my
specialty right guys
oh oh there's a jumpy pump
that's something at least that'll tide
me over
there's the chain i got the chain and
the jumpy pump i think those are the
only two ingredients i really need
oh man i just need the duct tape now and
an extra fuse because i used the one
over here but that's all on the other
side
oh god damn it ah [ __ ] ah
give get me out of here get me out of
here please please please just let me
out of here please
oh my god
okay that's still not even close to
where it's supposed to be i don't even
know why but
it is what it is
how does he keep doing that how does he
keep popping up out of nowhere
god damn it son of a [ __ ] i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna run him i'll i don't
care i'll run him all the way to the
other end of the goddamn
ship i'm not losing this again in the
same
[ __ ] way because it decides to give
me everything i need on the
episode where [ __ ] slimy i'm too
too sick for this
there we go jesus god damn it finally
ah goddammit [ __ ] jesus ah
you son of a [ __ ] every time
you stupid sack of crap i didn't even
get it down here
i'll screw you oh [ __ ] alarm
god damn it where's it gotta be that's
the question where does it need to be
like like how do i let go of it
i don't know that seems right i guess
wait what is okay lower the okay escape
the ship okay i did it i did it
i did what i set out to do so i just
need to get down there and
off this [ __ ] ship if this isn't it
if this is wrong if i'm doing anything
wrong
i am going to strangle everybody
okay oh
god finally and that's it i
escaped and there's nothing else to it
that's not even the same ship i was on
god oh oh
oh man oh i feel so
ill god you guys don't know what i went
through to get that and you're probably
wondering why
but then again it's me oh god i think
i'm gonna throw up
i feel so sick oh that was just such an
endeavor
i just didn't want to do it again and
avid turned into vanish where i couldn't
[ __ ] get it every single time i get
so close
oh man oh
oh man oh i do not know why that was
such a problem oh i don't know why
i don't know why uh
but i am done i'm done with monstrum
it's obviously there
aren't alternate endings if you do it
another way
but man i am done have pity on me for
how much work i put into this cause i've
been playing this for more than two and
a half hours
in the last hour and a half i was
nauseous and sick and just wanted it to
be over so badly
oh man so i'm gonna end this quick cause
i gotta go lay down
thank you all so much for watching let
me know if you what you think of my
performance in the comments below please
be gentle oh man just understand how
much i went through to get this done for
you guys
so thank you everybody so much for
watching check out my other games that
i've done in the past
that took less time than this
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
let's see what this ghost ego is gonna
do to me
i did it oh i thought for you i would
have to be stuck on that forever